what do you know about black the glass
ceiling black community's always trying
to like be like hey we we want this
representation we want to be at this
point want to be taken seriously
thank you I I'm gonna be all sorts are
wrong today of course I have heard of
the same black don't crack
I mean I'm just hoping that it's super
me why people can live for a very long
time and not look old that people are
beautiful they'll be great I figure out
who's the younger version of the black
suburban I'm afro Latino so I know this
[ __ ] so I got this down goddamn she
looks beautiful in each one maybe I can
look at her neck closer okay you know
what
I'm just gonna have to gauge them like
her style I'm gonna say B she's younger
indeed let's go with a actually a is the
younger version goddamn put my life on
it what is wrong with you
yes I put my life on it well I don't
matter Oh told you
awesome awesome I really couldn't tell
that was a guess there's no way I gotta
believe in that intuition okay this is
not even fair he's literally wearing the
same damn think you guys are trying to
throw me off man he lives the same
unfortunately I know that once you get a
little bit and age as a black man your
hair doesn't come in like I used to so
I'm gonna go with a a as my final answer
I will bet my life on that you wouldn't
go with picture B boom I am good at this
oh four - I'm so good right now
Liam this one's kind of hard though tell
you Washington she looks the exact same
is this she's got not one wrinkle makeup
a little more out there and a B is a
little more conservative but maybe she's
making up for it for being younger it
looks like she has a weave in the bottom
one so I think I'm gonna go with the top
picture she is younger in picture a just
cuz she has a little bit more baby hairs
I'm gonna go with B being the youngest
though he is the younger Kerry
Washington I'll go ahead and bet my life
on it cuz I have nothing to lose first
one wrong oh now it's like more intense
like it's more pressure now I've been
perfect
Will Smith that's my boy I love Will
Smith alright so with him I'm looking at
his eyes
in picture a he's kind of got that like
a little sexy salt-and-pepper thing
going on well maybe you did that on
purpose to confuse me see it's all about
that hairline that's the thing he's kind
of like Obama the beginning of the
presidency and like picture B and he's
like kind of like Obama now like picture
a I really want to get this one right
I've been perfect every time
why are you trying to play games with me
I think hey no we're going with a Will
Smith is younger in pictures he's older
in a B is the younger Will Smith I'm
very confident about this I'm right
though that's a commis thought uh-huh
celebrate what what right damn he's all
like grayed out and old and like like
the king in this photo like what's the
hell he must have really remembered to
get some of that damn guy yo what's man
step away from that
which is witchcraft you get younger
woody what's your secret man post game
analysis I didn't do as well as I
thought I was I thought I needed so
three four forests not bad you kind of
set up to fail I think I did fairly well
my goal was fine when I was with
Gabrielle Union after that I was like I
don't trust myself anymore like as they
get older they get hotter for some
reason I have to say black does not
crack I mean I'm just gonna keep
moisturizing every day I need to see
like what lotion it feeling like she's
you know eating like seaweed like what's
going on